this is the aggression dominance gas
port former WWE star shad gaspard has
gone missing according to multiple
reports shad went missing on Sunday
during a swim at Venice Beach with his
ten year old son the two were reportedly
among a group of swimmers caught in a
strong rip current around 4 p.m.
according to reports lifeguards raced
into the water to pull everyone out
including shad Sun one witness at the
scene told TMZ that shad directed
rescuers to help his son first and
reportedly another big wave crashed down
on shad and he has not been located
since the 39 year old pro wrestlers
wife's Ileana was reportedly at the
beach too she shared this pic of her
husband on her instace story asking fans
to message her directly if they have
info adding we want to know if he's been
seen and where shad was a big star with
the WWE back in the day making up
one-half of the tag team crime time with
his partner JTG what you
and don't let people like Jay T G stand
in your way over the last few weeks shad
and silly Anna had been doing what lots
of married couples have been doing
during quarantine tick-tocking
this said we've both been dancing all
this time and shad shared this message
with fans hey buddy just want to send
you guys messaging you know just
everybody calm down
relax obviously father